good morning Hank it's Tuesday today is
the 9th day of Pizza missive to
celebrate today's video comes to you in
9 very special parts that was part 1 the
intro part 2 the unabashed promotion of
saleable goods so there are only a few
days left to order all your pizza miss
stuff from dftba.com all these beautiful
Pizza John shirts and the pizza John PJs
and everything else is only available
till the end of pizza mess part 3
good news so I don't want to minimize or
ignore the torrent of bad news currently
washing over the world but I did want to
call your attention to one piece of
extraordinarily good news that I think
has gone underreported it's just been
announced that global carbon emissions
are expected to be nearly flat in 2016
marking the third straight year of no
carbon emission growth that's really
good news unfortunately it's not good
enough news because emissions are still
far too high to limit post industrial
warming to below two degrees Celsius but
it's important because it underscores
that humanity can reach its other goals
without increasing emissions like the
global economy grew by about 3% this
year and both poverty and disease burden
were reduced our three bad news the UN
has just reported that 2016 will almost
certainly be the hottest year in
recorded human history and worrisome lis
that record will likely only stand until
2017 climate change is real humans are
causing it and the people of the future
will judge us on how we dealt with it
part 5 more good news AFC Wimbledon the
fan owned English soccer team who wear
dftba on their shorts have had an
astonishingly successful first season in
the third tier of English football 17
games into the season they are just
three points from a playoff spot while
the franchise currently playing in
Milton Keynes is in the relegation zone
all of this is just further proof that
we are living in the best sports
timeline of the entire multiverse and
also the worst everything else timeline
part 6 on a bashed promotion of saleable
goods while you're over at dftba.com
picking up this comfortable and
fashionable Pizza John hoodie why not
buy an AFC Wimbledon nerdfighteria scarf
all proceeds go to the club and maybe if
we sell enough scarves they will make it
back to the playoffs and I will get to
go to Wembley and feel like this again
part 7 more bad news so Hank one of my
favorite songwriters Leonard Cohen died
last week he was everything I want to be
when I grow up empathetic and smart
without ever being condescending or cold
and he also gave me one of the central
ideas in my book Paper Towns I'm gonna
put a link to some of my favorite
Leonard Cohen songs in the doobly-doo
below for you
enjoy party more good news a mid loss
there is still great art being made in
the world
quick side story when I was fifteen I
wrote this extremely sincere and
terrible paper for English about how
there could never be another great work
of fiction because dusty etske was dead
and then like four months later we read
Toni Morrison Song of Solomon and Tony
Kushner's Angels in America and I was
like oh okay I would like to file a
retraction anyway 20 years later dust is
key is still dead and there are still
truly great books being written most
recently I've been completely astonished
by this book what is not yours is not
yours but I'll have many more book
recommendations in my forthcoming
holiday gift book roundup in the
meantime if there are books that you
would suggest to me please do so in
comments thanks part 9 the outro so I
think I'm gonna close out my part of
pizza Masson Thursday with an
old-fashioned question Tuesday because
you know what better day to do it so
please leave your questions ideally
brief ones in the comment section below
and I thought I'd leave you today with
some of my favorite Leonard Cohen lines
ring the bells that still can ring
forget your perfect offering there's a
crack in everything that's how the light
gets in and screen oh look it's that
book that I liked in pizza miss merchant
a couple of my favorite Leonard Cohen
songs and perhaps most importantly a
money from rosianna self care bunny is
here to remind you to take care of
yourself because there is only one of
you and the world is lucky to have you